Product placement is a subtle art and when
it’s done well, a few seconds of footage
can instantly raise the profile of a given
brand.
Perhaps the best known example of this is
the use of Reece’s Pieces in E.T., which
saw a 65% boost in sales almost overnight.
This makes it kind of fitting that arguably
the worst example of product placement in
a movie appeared in a shameless rip-off of
E.T. called Mac and Me.
(Even the title was taken from E.T., as the
working title for E.T. had once been E.T.
and Me.)
Released in 1988, six years after E.T., to
a chorus of zero and one star reviews, Mac
and Me has become somewhat infamous in film
circles for being one of the single worst
movies ever made.
(Despite the editor of this article having
extremely fond recollections of the film as
a child…
I see now that this must be like Knight Rider;
if you loved that show as a kid, do yourself
a favour and don’t try to re-watch it as
an adult…)
While critics of the time panned almost every
aspect of the Mac and Me, the most common
complaint amongst the sea of bile directed
towards this cinematic monstrosity was the
ludicrous amount of painfully obvious product
placement it contained.
Particular attention was drawn to the inexplicable
amount of screen-time dedicated to both Coca-Cola
and McDonald’s, which are prominently featured
in almost every key scene in the entire movie.
For those who’ve not seen this cinematic
classic, as noted, the film’s “plot”
is an unabashed knock-off of E.T.’s, focusing
on a stranded alien called MAC (which is an
acronym for Mysterious Alien Creature, and
totally “not” a ham-fisted allusion to
anything to do with McDonald’s…) who befriends
a wheelchair bound young man called Eric Cruise
while trying to reunite itself with its family.
If that wasn’t on the nose enough, the alien
is also being pursued by a shady government
agency.
The two films even had a near identical budget
of $13 million for Mac and Me vs. $10 million
for E.T.
(When adjusting for inflation for the 1988
Mac and Me and the 1982 E.T., that comes out
to $26 million and $25 million respectively
today.)
This brings us to the product placement.
For starters, one of the trailers for the
film started with a direct message from Ronald
McDonald who is shown reading a copy of the
script which is the same color scheme as his
outfit.
Ronald also featured heavily in commercials
and posters for the film, in some cases only
having his billing preceded by the logo for
the company that produced the film.
Ronald also briefly appears in the film’s
most infamous scene, which features an impromptu
almost 10 minute long choreographed breakdance
featuring dozens of dancers inside and around
a McDonald’s restaurant that is never adequately
explained.
This continues even as the plot unfolds around
the dancers who are oblivious to the government
stooges chasing a boy and his alien friend
disguised in a teddy bear outfit.
But we’re not done yet- as if having about
10% of the film’s runtime spent inside a
McDonald’s full of people exuberantly dancing
wasn’t overt enough, the film also features
a main character who works at McDonald’s
and wears her uniform in every scene she appears
in, most of which she wasn’t at work for.
That’s not to mention the Oscar-worthy dialogue
in which the family discusses how incredibly
good Big Macs are.
As for Coca-Cola, along with being prominently
featured in several scenes, either in characters’
hands or handily placed McDonald’s cups,
it ends up being a key plot point later in
the movie when the main character uses it
to revive Mac’s ailing alien parents.
Yes, this movie features a scene in which
a character is shown bringing someone back
to life by pouring Coca-Cola into their dying
mouth.
This is then immediately followed by a scene
showing the same aliens risking detection
to buy more Coca-Cola.
Coca-Cola, along with Skittles are also the
only things the eponymous Mac is shown to
consume, with the latter being used to lure
him out of hiding like a grotesque parody
of the Reece’s Pieces scene in E.T.
The film also features a rather prominent
plug for the department store Sears, when
it is revealed the main character’s mother
relocated her entire family to another state
because she was offered a job there.
Unsurprisingly from all this, the director
and screenwriter of the film, Stewart Raffill,
noted the genesis of the film was hardly conducive
to producing quality entertainment, despite
its relatively high budget for the time:
Mac and Me?
That was another movie where somebody called
me up and he was a producer who had worked
on quite a few films.
He’d made a lot of big movies, but he decided
he want to make his own movie.
And he raised the money from one of the main
partners at McDonalds—I think, like, the
produce provider for McDonalds—and he put
up the money to do that movie with the understanding
that the proceeds from that movie would go
to the Ronald McDonald Foundation.
So I was hired out of the blue.
And the producer asked me to come down to
the office.
So I did and he had a whole crew there, a
whole crew on the payroll.
It was amazing.
He had the transportation captain.
The camera department head.
The AD.
The Production Manager.
He had everybody already hired and I said,
“Well, what’s the script?”
And he said, “We don’t have a script.
I don’t like the script.
You have to write the script.
You’re gonna have to write it quick so prep
the movie and write the script on the weekends.”
Yeah, so I’d go and lock myself in a hotel
on Friday night, write ’til Monday, anticipate
what the locations were going to be, go out
and find the locations, design the aliens
and all that stuff.
It was kind of a messy way to make a movie.
(Note: the producer in question, R.J. Louis,
among many other movies, also produced The
Karate Kid, Karate Kid Part II, and Ocean’s
Eleven.)
One thing we can say for certain though is
that although this movie has been rightly
panned and called one of the worst movies
of all time, it does feature a silver lining-
Jade Calegory, the actor who played the main
character, Eric Cruise.
Now for most actors this role would have been
an embarrassing footnote they’d rather not
discuss.
(Fun fact: this movie was the first one Jennifer
Aniston was ever in.)
For Calegory, though, it was one of the defining
moments in his young life, because, like his
character, he too is disabled, having been
born with spina bifida.
Why is this important?
Well, to begin with, disabled characters in
Hollywood films are almost always played by
people who have no such disability, and this
was even more so the case in the 1980s.
But far more importantly, the film never makes
a big deal about the character’s handicap.
It isn’t an integral part of his character
or plot and it isn’t played for laughs or
sympathy; he’s refreshingly, and very purposefully,
portrayed as just a normal kid doing otherwise
normal things until he encounters his little
alien friend.
The fact that he’s in a wheelchair isn’t
even commented on by any character in the
movie.
Moreover, the fact that the kid was in a wheelchair
both in the film and in real life wasn’t
overtly mentioned in the marketing campaigns
either.
As Raffill note, “…when they finished
it was as if the fact that they used a real
encumbered person to play the [character]
didn’t mean anything to even the people
who lived in the world.”
While in a perfect world this shouldn’t
be notable in any way, as noted in a LA Times
article from the time of the film’s release,
this was (and still is) a huge deal because
it marked one of the exceptionally few times
in film history where a disabled actor had
secured a role for a character that wasn’t
“written disabled” and didn’t have the
disability made into a defining character
trait or plot element.
In stark contrast to this, Calegory later
noted when he showed up for other auditions
to play various disabled characters, not only
were the characters always “written disabled”,
but it was generally very obvious that the
casting directors had no interest in hiring
an actual disabled person.
“They were just kind of bringing disabled
people in there just to say they did, you
know what I mean?”
Fitting then that in Mac and Me they found
a boy, Calegory, who’d never acted before
at the time and whose only real qualifications
for the role was that he was a kid who had
a disability, but was otherwise pretty much
like any other young boy- exactly the message
they were going for.
Speaking of this, according to his mother,
among Calegory’s many other childhood exploits,
when he was five years old and literally only
a few minutes out of the hospital after surgery
and still in a full body cast, she turned
her back on him for just a moment… only
to turn back to find him flying by precariously
perched spread-eagle on a skateboard he’d
found somewhere.
Calegory later noted of his attitude on life:
You shouldn’t dwell on what you can’t
do.
Focus on what you can do.
And the more you see what you can do, the
more you come to realize there are no limitations
in life.
In a 1988 interview, a then 12-year-old Jade
Calegory revealed that he’d gotten so sick
of answering the question “Why are you in
a wheelchair” that his stock response was
to look the person asking in the eye and say
“Vietnam”.